alors il y a donc ce soir un bilan de 69
morts en France après 2 jours de tempête
la seconde la nuit dernière a tué 24
personnes dont 12 dans le sol
département de la Charente Maritime nous
commençons donc par celui-ci avec La
Rochelle où la ville des hioirs a été
carrément mise chaos par les vents les
pluie à l'intérieur des terres comme
dans les ports au petit matin c'était un
désastre nos envoyés spéciaux Christophe
de valembrass et Alain darégrand nous le
racontent les voiliers magnifiques du
port des Minimes relégués au rang de
vulgaire branche morte cette nuit la
tempête les a arraché à leur splendeur
et les a jeté là
agonisant et je suis consterné par ce
que je vois ce matin je me suis promené
dansun les parcs
c'est c'est terrible et quand je vois ce
désastre à côté c'est c'est dantesque de
voir ça c'est jamais j'ai vu ça jamais
jamais j'ai eu une peur cette nuit
incroyable j' vite au minime là je se
demandaer ce qu' allait arriver car à La
Rochelle on s'attendait à une tempête
mais certainement pas celle-ci tellement
violentes des rafales à plus de 160 kmh
inimaginable j'étais chez des amis là
dans La Rochelle puis il y a un gros
arbre énorme qui est déjà tombé sur la
maison alors on est venu voir là mais on
s'est fait on est tombé dans une tornade
énorme j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie ça
fait 20 ans je fais du bateau j'ai
jamais vu ça le Levant nous a poussé
dans les rues elle mais au gymnastique
on pouvait pas s'arrêter oé de
s'accrocher après les
murs jamais dans ces rue le vent n'a
hurleré si fort si dur les avenues
illuminées quand l'électricité
capricieuse le permet se font piégeuse
dangereuse le vent est là et le vieux
port a du mal à contenir la
menace sur les routes de campagne toute
proche le danger vient des Ares des
dizaines des centaines d'racinés par
d'irrésistibles rafales trop d'appel les
secours sont submergés alors on se
débrouille tout seul pour passer malgré
les risques comment vous allez faire B
accrocher la la sangue à l'AR et
accrocher au camion et tirer il n'z pas
de de matériel spécialisé ah benah non
on se débrouille avec nos mains La
Rochelle s'est éveillé meurtrie ce matin
partout les séquelles de la force
dévastatrice du vent voici tout ce qu'il
reste des barrages flottant poulmar
installé la semaine dernière pour
protéger le port du foule de l'herica
dans toute la ville les dégâts sont
spectaculaires et il faudra encore
plusieurs jours pour en mesurer la
véritable
ampleur